president biden at the white house
declaring for the first time so far that
he now does believe that vladimir putin
will
militarily invade ukraine the president
just getting off the phone with our
european allies who he says are united
and determined and are preparing a
massive amount of economic sanctions
against the russians who he says is
pushing out a massive amount of
propaganda all over the place and
we don't know any more than that
is basically what he said greg gutfeld
your reaction to what you heard it
sounds like it's happening
i don't i don't i don't know what to
believe because they also they also had
some interesting intel on afghanistan
when he said
it was hard to read putin's mind i get
that
so why don't you just ask him do you
know what i mean i mean this was
there's always these psychological
barriers in these things and
why don't you just ask him what's on his
mind and just sit there this is what we
did with north korea this is why trump
de-escalated a psychological threat by
actually asking the dude what's your
problem and he removed a psychological
threat from the table look america has
america would love for you to join the
rest of the world and not be some
regressive tyrant but we're not planning
on blowing you up so maybe you could
point your missiles somewhere else and
it goes and then that's the end of it
you have to you have to remove the
psychological barrier it would be
interesting there's only one person you
need to talk to right it's putin just
like ask him let him talk this this
there's something else going on here
that is that feels very very
manufactured i don't know what it is but
it just seems to me that what it is
go for it it's jake sullivan yeah jake
sullivan is the national security
advisor he's in deep yogurt in the
durham probe and he's been the one
saying we have so much intelligence uh
an invasion is imminent they said that
last friday it's the next friday here we
are um i don't think putin is going to
invade and i don't understand why we are
running point when germany is the one
who's got the most invested they've got
the energy relationship with russia
russia needs their money they need their
markets uh therefore with a new
chancellor he should make his mark on
the rest of europe and cool things down
with putin he's got a much better shot
than the dum-dums in this administration
who blew it in 2014 and they're gonna
blow it again and i know that because
con la harris is the point person yes
she's going to be a repetitive she's
going to say the same thing over and
over again betraying her lack of
knowledge on the entire situation she's
just going to go we stand together we
are standing together here here we are
together standing
it's uh don't forget the hashtag there's
got to be a hashtag yes there's always a
hashtag
but you know the amazing part of it is
that he's convinced that putin has made
the decision to invade but he says it's
hard to read his mind so what are you
basing that on okay what are you basing
it on did you talk to him or are you
basing it on the fact that they've got
the planes out they've got the tanks
that are you know in position they
called the russian reserve which
apparently is only used when they're
about to occupy so putin is playing this
game whatever it is and he's got these
nuclear drills that he's going to he's
going to be
doing these drills this weekend then you
have to say okay are you basing it on
that because if you are it's just a game
and you don't know what putin is doing
but i agree with you kennedy i really
believe that that jake sullivan and
blink and there are a bunch of doofuses
and then you put the queen at the top of
that kamala harris who doesn't know
anything we're sending her over there to
tell them that we stand with the
ukrainians first of all we can't fight
with ukrainians because they're not a
nato country what are we going to do
shake their hands when they come back
for war what is this all about well
leslie it looks like the intelligence
community believes and has told the
president that they're going in and that
intelligence is either right or that
intelligence is either wrong and we just
don't know that but you could tell by
the president's somber tone and this was
pretty somber that he thinks it's
happening any day now this was different
than he usually is his tone was
different i agree but the message is the
same and look if it has a bill and it
has webbed fee and it quacks it's a duck
and when you look at over 10 years of
the of what vladimir putin has done
first of all vladimir putin has wanted
ukraine as bad as a teenage boy has
wanted the centerfold and playboy since
before he was vladimir putin really
badly and and in addition when you have
90 000 additional troops you have 150
000 troops there right now one two you
have these small cyber attacks and
that's how they start and then they
escalate and then three you have this
propaganda that's the mo for the
invasion that's what he did last time
and that's what he's done before so why
would he be doing anything differently
now but why didn't obama stop him in
2014 when they annexed crimea and when
they they you know when they declared a
war back then well you brought up a very
good point and you took one of my points
but i didn't
know one ukraine is not a nato country
and two this is one area where we have
bipartisan support even though it's
symbolic the senate has passed a
resolution echoing the sentiments of the
president both democrats and republicans
we don't want military involvement now
we didn't want it barack obama was
president yeah but he actually announced
crimea i mean that that's pretty
significant
what are you going to do there though
let let's get some reaction to joe
biden's speech from jennifer griffin who
is live at the pentagon all right
jennifer you heard what he said it looks
like he thinks putin's going in what
changed so significantly do you think in
the last 24 hours
well jesse i think first of all i need
to level set with the conversation i've
just been listening to
what we are witnessing right now is not
something that just changed in the last
24 hours if you go back to notes that
i've been sending out for the last two
weeks this is something we've been
watching in terms of you have commercial
satellite imagery you have the build up
of forces the type of forces the numbers
of forces things that we've been
told in advance to look for in terms of
some of the disinformation that is
already starting to uh to appear the
false flag operations in the donbass
region all of that is ticking up this is
something that through a web of of
intelligent sources as well as uh the
commerce the in surveillance imagery
that you can see with your own eyes uh
this is something that has been accepted
it has been expected they have been
watching it very closely and they feel
that they are now in the final hours and
days in which there is still a small
possibility to
try to get putin to accept the off-ramp
of diplomacy but as you heard from
president biden and it is extremely
significant
what he just said in terms of from his
point of view uh putin has already made
a decision that coincides with what i am
hearing here at the pentagon from
western intelligence sources from
western allies the this is a very
different situation than i've heard
comparisons to the iraq war and wmd and
how do we know we're seeing it with our
own eyes if you can't look at the kind
of iskander
missile
battalions that are now in belarus 30
000 russian troops there the kind half
of his uh air force has now been
deployed toward ukraine i'm told in just
moments ago from a senior defense
official that 40
of his
190 000 troops who are on the border
with ukraine are now in attack positions
that is something that we have been
waiting for they were in those barracks
they are now moving into assault
positions they could move in a matter of
hours or days and this is something that
needs to be watched closely this is not
some backwater this is europe this is
one of the largest military actions
being threatened to redraw the map of
europe since world war ii it's going to
be bloody we've heard estimates that 50
000 civilians will be killed one to five
million refugees will be sent on the
road the level of destruction and the
bloodiness of this uh invasion if it
moves forward and again they are doing
what they can
to try and get uh lavrov and blinken to
meet and to say that if there's an
invasion before that meeting on
wednesday that that then those sanctions
and everything else goes into place and
we're in a whole different world at that
point but right now every american
should be watching this and knowing that
this is deadly serious this is not some
wag the dog situation to even mention
the durham probe
in the same sentence as what we just
what we know and what we can see with
our own eyes in terms of the military
build up and knowing what vladimir putin
is capable of i served in moscow from
1996 to 99 i watched as vladimir putin
rose i remember the apartment blocks
that were blown up by his kgb his fsb as
a pretext to go into chechnya go look at
those images of chechnya and how carpet
bombed chechnya was when the russian
military moves in this is not a
precision
of small pinpointed strike this will be
the full weight of the russian military
going into ukraine if someone doesn't
stop it in the coming days jennifer
griffin thank you so much we appreciate
it
you look like you wanted to say
something well i want to say a couple of
things first of all our electric grid in
this country is balkanized it's like a
third world country even the military is
connected to our electric grid so we are
very vulnerable to a cyber attack to the
electric grid it could throw us back and
i don't and i'm not being you know
dramatic here but it could throw us back
into the dark ages you mean candlelight
dinner yeah candlelight dinners but
right now but not romantically no food
okay that's number one number two if
this invasion window is so obvious and
we're in the right in the midst of it
why is the president of ukraine
zielinski going to munich this way and
why is he the most relaxed leader in the
face of an invasion i've never seen a
guy more relaxed that was my point but
thank you very much for finishing my
sentence
[Laughter]
there has been a little contrast between
the intensity on this side you could buy
them versus compared to
i don't know i don't know it
this kind of swirling uh like oh it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen forgive me fifty thousand
refugees already they gotta count it i
know it's it's but we've been hearing
this we've been hearing this and it's
like
nobody i mean don't start giving us crap
because we don't know what's true
because we've been lied to repeatedly
repeatedly right i think uh what people
are seeing uh through the satellite
images are that they have amassed a
massive amount of soldiers and armaments
right around that country and you know
what happened in world war one what
happened in world war ii it's a bloody
theater united states usually has to
come and bail those people out we do
have the strongest military in the world
and we're allied with all these nato
countries the fear is getting sucked
into this bloody theater and having it
spiral price of gas goes to four dollars
here in the united states and we get hit
with cyber attacks yeah there's a lot of
concern there's also some concern that
this administration is you know being
trolled into
a hot conflict with a nuclear power you
know it's it's it's not exciting it's
not a football game you know the we we
are two
nuclear powers about to get into a fight
with each other and would germany come
over and have our back if justin trudeau
and his handsome hair decided to launch
an invasion into the united states i
don't think they would so i i go back to
why are we the ones running point on
this and why are people so excited at
this prospect you know look what
happened in afghanistan i'm not just
talking about the botched withdrawal and
you know to you the point you made
earlier the bad intelligence on the
withdrawal and how quickly that country
would collapse why are we now trusting
the exact same intelligence apparatus to
give us information here when the
president can't say it plainly so yes i
i do
i share a lot of distrust we have been
lied to repeatedly by the department of
defense about afghanistan for decades uh
why are why would they all of a sudden
come clean now when we also know the nsa
and cia are spying on americans
illegally
so
to kennedy's point about trusting the
intelligence they they've seen uh i
guess
all of the satellite images show the
encirclement of the country so that's
not in dispute it's it's not something
that's in the shadows you can see
clearly where they've surrounded the
country it's a matter of what the
president can do
diplomatically because we're not going
in to deter him militarily we don't have
an alliance with that country and we
don't want that country in nato to begin
with right we're not going to say that
because you can't let the russians tell
us who we're going to be allies with 10
years 15 years later but it's pretty
clear we don't want him in nato all
right but that's that biden didn't say
that clearly yeah but putin i don't
think he even cares he just wants the
country well it proves
if putin says that that's one of
what if this is a fact-finding mission
you you prepare to invade just to see
what the other side has well that's what
i think and that's what i thought was
happening for the last two weeks i think
don't they already know to see how we
were gonna we might have a we might have
a weapon that we don't even know we have
right and it's you it's me you are a
secret woman for it
i don't know leslie is there anything
different okay the president okay
where's the grassy knoll underneath the
table okay
look
vladimir putin reminds me of the the
silver black that gorillas that you know
do this right he's all about sorry to
the sound people there yeah he's he's
all about power he's all about money you
know we we need to take a deep breath
the western world controls over 50
of the world's economy china and russia
combined less than 20
so when it comes to money we're going to
win and that's why i think that we see
confidence not just in biden but in our
allies like germany and others
and in addition we know we're not going
to send in in the military right we're
not going to send in the military and we
have bipartisan support and not sending
in the military and we also have
bipartisan support on the sanctions so
you know he's taking he's having his
power grab which is ukraine which he's
always wanted but what's going to happen
after and
i do think that not just president biden
but i do think along with our western
allies he's going to be smacked so hard
financially that he will regret the
statement he knows but
do you think he can stomach the
sanctions and say i'd rather gobble up
the country no i don't think he can
stumble this uh stomach the sanctions
and i was just going to agree i don't
know that he has the money to last there
for more than a couple of weeks did you
just agree with me yeah i did i did in
terms of russia
economically surviving and invading and
i mean how does he pay for it occupying
this is like in placing saddles when you
know they created a fake town they used
all the wood they could possibly find to
create exact replicas of themselves and
that is what russia is doing with their
military they have every single thing
they've got and one's right out there to
try and make it look they've got much
more waiting in the wings and that is a
falsehood to your point their their
economy isn't shambled people in that
country are hurting they don't want this
they can't afford but they have eastern
ukraine why do they need all of ukraine
well there's someone to explain that
they need it as a buffer militarily and
they want to go and reclaim the old
empire that they lost that's what they
can afford
the british the romans i mean since the
beginning of time men have been wanting
to get more and more territory you know
what if there was a female leader of
russia she never would have invaded so
leslie it's all about men right it's all
about the gorillas since the beginning
of time it's been messed up you know
what we're on the pink team over here
catherine the
grapes wow you just got catherine the
greatest didn't you see that i did get
katherine yeah yeah i'll give you that
right all right well i think just to
recap americans are concerned about the
rise in gas prices and if there's a
cyber war back and forth in response to
the sanctions that could also hurt us
too until then we don't know what's
going to happen is going to solve this
pamela is on the job czar we're going to
she's got she handled our border she
could definitely handle another
country's border that's right and she's
always wanted to go to europe yeah
that's what she told lester holt all
right we're going to continue to follow
the breaking news with ukraine hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else